my name is Keith Robinson I'm a captain
in the United States Army and I'm here
on Columbia University's campus to see
my daughter graduate her name is Ruby
Danielle Robinson and I'm very proud of
her
my daughter does not know I'm coming
today so she's gonna be very surprised
when I when she sees me we've gone
through back and forth and I had to let
her know that it wasn't possible for me
to be here because up to about two weeks
ago it didn't look like this was gonna
happen so we started juggling things and
I got with my general and he got me out
as fast as possible and you know God is
good in so many ways it's like every
stop along the way they were like can
you leave in 15 minutes and I was like
oh yeah oh yeah I can leave in 15
minutes so no she didn't know that I was
going she's gonna be very surprised when
I see her congratulations lady
[Applause]
Oh
we have him here in the flesh means so
much to me I didn't expect it at all I
didn't think it was possible so I'm so
happy about it to have your parents at
your graduation is a big thing we talked
about to about two weeks ago and I think
we came to the conclusion that I wasn't
gonna make it and then about a week ago
when my general started went to work and
started trying to make this happen for
me everything happened really fast and
you know 14 and a half hour flight from
Kuwait to DC another three and a half
hours to Denver
the next day turn around and fly back
here I mean I haven't had time to stop
and think about it myself but when I saw
her it was like it was all worth it I
really didn't expect him to be there and
I was kind of upset about that but I
knew he had other duties to do in
Afghanistan so when he came I was so
excited
[Applause]